[Música]
eu prefiro ver um filho morto há um
filho gay família gay não existe mas
você já transou com um homem
eu respeito mas não precisa ser na minha
frente
precisa ficar se exibindo assim tudo bem
são lésbicas mas tem que se vestir que
nem homem
cada frase um pé atrás pois se como dar
um passo à frente nessas normas nos
tornaríamos nada mais que um fantoche se
construindo pelo permitido construída
pelos padrões normas da sociedade
[Música]
1 a votos uma votos uma foto com o novo
votos uma foto uma foto em uma foto
estampada numa grande avenida
o novo voto a voto
brincar no jogo pela mãe
o voto a voto a voto
na denúncia de perigo na televisão
uma foto estampada na avenida
uma foto publicada no jornal uma fonte
na denúncia de perigo na televisão
a placa de censura não gosto de verdade
uma taxa de coco meu corpo e não
recomenda
a sociedade
a taxa de sutura no meu rosto disse
[Música]
não recomendado a não recomendar nossa
sociedade
[Música]
admiro
a agência péssima aparência e que
regressem tipo ii
ao amado
[Música]
gente que jura no meu rosto
a sociedade
a taxa é de costume
o jeito
a sociedade
vaca de cintura no meu rosto e estão
o nome
[Música]
o
ah ah ah ah
[Música]
o forró
i sérgio não crer no céu
[Música]
diga não a aberração homem errado
não recomendado não recomendado a
sociedade num comendado recomendado
[Música]
[Aplausos]